maybe we can also ask your opinion on
the other game yeah very exciting game
yeah this is kind of this game was
this game was crazy
oh he's thinking for a long time yeah i
think he's thinking like i don't know
half now yeah i don't know for how long
but
he's he's nearly an hour down on the
clock now but
you have given a rook you should have
been prepared for this
but
maybe he he can play it all the way to
black's pieces are not developed for you
it's also new you haven't analyzed this
no i have not
i don't play this opening yeah neither
of the coloring yeah so with fresh eyes
to this position what would be the first
things that come to mind
before push by four yeah
i mean we thought the same it's hard to
come up with anything else really
and what what's black going to wrong i
think e6 and we should say
yeah the e5 is losing you know
yeah i i don't want to do i don't want
to give temples more i just play e6 we
should be found in the castle
okay okay but then after e6 i think then
bishop takes
one
and then if castle you can just take on
d6 on rook d1 and take on a1 even that
no i think this is
hopeless yeah